>> IT'S NOT JUST LIKE
PAPADOPOULOS DROPS IN OUT OF
NOWHERE.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THIS STUFF GOING
ON IN THE SUMMER BEFORE WE GET
TO PAPADOPOULOS INFORMATION, YOU
HAVE ALL OF THIS INFORMATION
COMING OUT ABOUT WHAT THE
RUSSIANS ARE DOING, WITH THE
HANG HACKING AND THE DUMPING OF
E-MAILS, INTENDED TO HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THE POLITICAL SYSTEM.
THEN IN THE MIDST OF THAT,
THAT'S WHEN WE GET THE
PAPADOPOULOS INFORMATION.
>> Laura: WELL, THAT'S FROM
FORMER GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE
FBI, JIM BAKER ABOUT OUR NEXT
GUEST.
GEORGE STEPHANOPOLOUS -- NO,
PAPADOPOULOS, SAID THAT HE HAS
ONLY JUST BEGUN TO LAY OUT THE
TIME LINE OF WHEN HE BELIEVES
THE OBAMA INTEL AGENCIES WERE
ATTEMPTING TO ENTRAP HIM.
HE JOINS US NOW.
GEORGE, WHAT HAVEN'T YOU
REVEALED TO DATE, HOW MANY
AGENCIES WERE COMING AFTER YOU,
ONE PERSON, AND SOMETHING THAT
THEY TRIED TO GET YOUR
GIRLFRIEND TO DO?
WHAT WAS THAT?
>> OH, MY GOD.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME, LAURA.
BESIDES THE FBI TRYING TO HAVE
MY THEN-GIRLFRIEND, NOW WIFE,
WEAR A WIRE TO TRY TO ENTRAP ME
HERSELF WHICH WAS COMPLETELY
CRAZY, SHE WAS AN ITALIAN
CITIZEN VISITING ME AS A
GIRLFRIEND, THEY SUBPOENAED HER
AND TRIED TO FLIP HER AGAINST
ME, INCREDIBLY BIZARRE.
WHAT WE BELIEVED THAT THEY
REALLY TAR GETTED HER FOR, SHE
KNEW ALL ABOUT JOSEPH MIPS AND
CONNECTIONS TO THE ITALIAN
GOVERNMENT AND HIS CONNECTIONS
IN EUROPE.
WE FOUND OUT TODAY THE ITALIAN
GOVERNMENT UNDER THE PRESIDENCY
OF THAT COUNTRY, THE PRIME
MINISTER, JUST FIRED THE HEADS
OF THREE INTEL AGENCIES IN
ITALY.
I THINK IT HAS TO DO WITH THE
PERSON, JOSEPH, WHO THE
PRESIDENT AND DIF ON NUNES AND
OTHER PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ASKING TO
EXAMINE MORE.
HE'S AT THE CORE OF THIS SCAM.
>> Laura: PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT
THIS FIGURE.
IT STARTS TO READ LIKE A JOHN
LECARRE NOVEL.
YOU'VE HEARD THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY'RE SAYING THIS WAS WELL
PREDICATED, BRENNAN LAST NIGHT,
WE'LL PLAY THE VIDEO.
HE WAS ON TELEVISION LAST NIGHT,
AGAIN.
AND CLAIMING THAT THIS WAS ALL
CO-A SETTIC.
-- COPASETIC.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THERE'S AN UNDERSTANDING HOW
STRONGLY PREDICATED THAT
INVESTIGATION WAS.
I WAS THERE IN THE SUMMER OF
'16, IT WAS WELL PREDICATED.
>> Laura: WELL PREDICATED,
GEORGE?
>> I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR, BY
THE TIME I JOINED THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN BEFORE MY NAME WAS
PUBLIC, AN FBI INTERMEDIARY AT A
COMPANY I USED TO WORK FOR IN
LONDON INTRODUCED ME TO THIS
PERSON THAT AT A SCHOOL, WHICH
THE CIA AND FBI TRAINS AT.
FAST FORWARD TO APRIL 2016, I'M
THE AUSTRALIAN GOVERNMENT IS
REACHING OUT FRYING TO CONNECT
WITH ME, 10 DOWNING STREET, AND
THEN WHICH I FIND SUSPICIOUS IS
THAT THE DIA REACHED OUT TO ME
AT THE U.S. EMBASSY IN LONDON.
TWO INDIVIDUALS, GREGORY BAKER
AND TERRANCE DUDLEY, JUST DAYS
BEFORE THIS INFAMOUS MEET HAGD
WITH ALEX DOWNER, TESTIFIED
UNDER OATH AND I'VE REPORTED
BOTH TO THE FBI AND BOB MULER
THAT I FELT HE WAS SPYING TO ME.
SOMETHING I WANT TO MAKE SURE
ABOUT THIS MEETING WITH DOWNER,
I DON'T THINK I WAS JUST
SUSPICIOUS HE WAS SPYING TO ME,
IN MY TRANSCRIPTS TO KRAN SKRETS
YOU SEE MARK MEADOWS AND JOHN
ASKING IF I WAS HANDED
TRANSCRIPTS WITH ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE THAT WERE RUNNING INTO
ME.
I SAID NO.
CONGRESS HAS STRIPTS, THEY KNOW,
THE PRESIDENT KNOWS THESE PEOPLE
WERE SPYING.
IT WILL BE A BIG BOMBSHELL.
>> Laura: OH, THIS IS GOOD.